[Music]
hello everyone this is one spinmaster
subpoena for sure I'm here at the San
Luis chess club and you are watching
games everyone should know by heart so
for today I've prepared some two games
one the first one that we're going to be
looking at is between ready and vocal
you both and the other one is going to
be another Judit Polgar game I was kind
of deciding what would be the best games
that everyone should know and well I
memorized them myself too so or at least
I tried we'll see so this game is pretty
I think this game is pretty fun and it
kind of shows the it was the start of
the hyper-modern so the game was played
in 1924 and you know ready I really like
this the ideas that have come up you
know in those years that you don't have
to occupy the center immediately you can
just let your opponent you know occupy
it first and then you know attack it
later and I'm very happy to know that
these ideas are still used nowadays
hopefully by some of the viewers and
people here and so ready to start with
Knight f3 d5 C for now okay some some
other ideas that that are played or not
with c4 sometimes ready also played with
what we saw earlier in the viewers
choice right with g3 Bishop g2 d3 and
then you can also play with e4 so there
are various systems but this game he
played c4 so I always enjoyed teaching
my more beginner students these kind of
things because they always ask me but
you said that it's so important to
occupy the center why do some of this
people not occupy it and then I said the
story and you know it's pretty fun it's
pretty nice too to be able to describe
those things as well hopefully you all
know these things already so I'm not
going to emphasize on it
g3 Knight f6 Bishop g2 this is something
pretty standard nowadays Bishop d6 any
of you playing this with user colors
none okay so like yes or no you play
Knight IFTA and with c4 okay okay I mean
I these are nice things to play
sometimes I'm because you're not really
showing whether it'll push d4 or not and
you always keep especially on this more
water you always keep ideas will be
three B shall be two you're not really
showing what you want to do maybe you'll
play the cut around maybe we'll just
play you know the English or or maybe if
if black plays C 5 for example maybe you
will you can take and play the reversed
Irish something like this right and you
have an extra tempo it should be fun so
anyways there are a lot of there are a
lot of options so but the loop of played
Bishop d6 in this position kind of you
know keeping the options opened with the
pawn with the C pawn Castle castle b3 so
now white protects this point of course
so I should mention this that if black
takes here early there are various ways
there some people do take and why does
take that pawn back eventually I've seen
some people actually try with 93 as well
and try to take it but you know you
typically don't want to give up the
center but you can play it if you want
to then you would play something with
Bishop d7 and and
96 or Bishop c6 and have a nice position
too but in this game black Castle b3 now
of course you don't really want to take
anymore because white has brought the
defense rook e8 Bishop b2
and Knight B to d7 so black has chosen
to play some kind of Queen's Gambit type
of system right if if white plays d4 in
this position we have the Queen's Gambit
and that's exactly what happened in the
game and black responded with c6 in my
opinion if you're trying to play the
Queen's Gambit I think you should
especially against the Catalan you
should try to figure out whether you
really need to play c6 fast or not and I
believe here b6 is another option for
black and the idea would be of course to
play Bishop e7 rook c8 and then play
just c5 directly you want to equalize
with black first and then get the
advantage so that would that would be
pretty equal in my opinion but okay
there's nothing wrong with c6 we can
consider that with right we can consider
we've gotten some pretty normal Catalan
no Knight B to d2 what is White's plan
in this position
Quincy - and prepare for eforea
certainly and some other ideas that were
were invented by Pillsbury not in this
particular position but with 95 and f/4
right those are nice ideas as well but
you definitely want to take your queen
out so here black made a mistake no it's
a dubious move but why is this mistake
and we know it nowadays you should
really take care of your pieces first of
all like play something in p6 Bishop e7
why move the knight there is no way like
if white wouldn't have taken that night
out and had played a move like rook e1
or something you know then yes maybe you
can play a move like 94 because you know
your other night will be able to come to
f6 and back it up although this is not
an outpost so you should always be ready
that white will move this Knight and
then play f3 and chase you away but
these ideas are prominent you see them
in a lot of games nowadays but but when
you don't have the point in f5 this is
not a stone wall this is just Marin type
of position Queens gambit type of
position you don't want to place a
knight there to allow the doubling of
the pawns it's not such a great such a
great idea for black
I think b6 which makes way more sense a
better plan for black is to try to play
c5 and equalize just get a symmetrical
more-or-less position and play on from
there so 94 what do we do it white why
is this move not such a great idea for
black
take a double prawns and you might tell
me now that these double pawns are not
weak because they are not on an open
file and they are linked to this it's an
island here like it's not two islands or
something but the thing is black is not
ready like it would have been much nicer
if there was a point in a five and black
would recapture with this pawn and then
have the F file like we have in the in
the Stonewall but here it's different
and now 95 and what do you do about your
pony me for can you play in this
position Knight f6 of course you can
it's legal but is it good
guys this point is going to be lost now
it's Queen c2 and black you see if black
had b6 Bishop d7 I would never tell you
this is not such a great idea you it's
often made my black but in this case
black is not ready to actually support
that point so Knight f6 doesn't works
and that's why in this position they had
to play a 5 + f5 with rook in the 8th
you know you don't get me wrong this
happens sometimes for black but not with
this setup with the rook in yet I mean
at least you need to have the rook in FA
to at least have some continuation of
plans on the on the King side the rook
has wasted a little bit of time so ready
played f3 here but I think it would have
been better to take their first bishop
or queen takes maybe Queen takes I've
seen a lot of people taking with the
Queen and the idea is that they think
the bishop in d7 is actually worse than
actually being in c8 because they want
to develop it to fianchetto it and now
after I think would have been a better
choice for white because we keep a nice
bone structure and well take we take
with which piece and if I play can I
play five cows
I only considered Bishop takes and if
Bishop takes I was playing Queen d2
first and then stuff so maybe I do the
same I don't play f3 immediately if
Queen takes yeah maybe maybe I also play
Queen d2 here if you play five what is
my idea yeah something like this
and there may be d5 to let you have
those that messed up majority maybe I
put even this F ro f rook to d1 rather
played f3 immediately which would have
allowed Bogoliubov to capture here first
hauntings now Bishop c5 check the King
has to go and now if I trade I think
black is doing alright because yes the
spaceship is messed up
but the position is closed neither of
your bishops have some clear future the
only small thing that black that white
has is the fact that they have a small
advantage because of this pond space
advantage but that's that's about it
with the bishop in c5 for controlling
the d6 square now let's say take with
this pond and we have ideas with a5
making sure that this Bishop will be
staying there forever and then their
ideas with a 5-4 very difficult for this
type of pawn structure
it's I think White's advantage here is
minimal
instead Bogoliubov made a change of move
order he took me the pawn like this
Bishop takes and no he didn't again he
didn't take any five he played Queen c7
now takes takes Bishop c5 King G to a
five
once again I'm okay with this position
with black what do you guys think who is
better here
slightly though right I mean you have
some if for ideas Quincy to review one
okay I can place my queen to
here is it's wrong it's wrong to play
queen g5 you have ideas with bishops
around yeah but I try not to do anything
when you put pushy for like I don't want
to take and help you get that I mean the
F file and they're gonna I'll just stay
maybe even g6 and I try to capture back
so that you have you'll have a past poem
but also weak phone so that Bishop will
be open ways oh you want to play Queens
you want you can certainly do that if
you want yeah but then you're going to
place this rook to d1 right so what will
you do with this other one you're just
temporary stop it quit g5 I also have 37
square for my queen and also have ideas
well right now they don't work but I
would have ideas with Bishop d4 well do
they work
no no they don't work because this this
oopsie
so I can play
it's a playable position but it's not a
big thing for white you have plans I
will not deny it but compared to the
game this would have been a much better
choice or black instead of play Queen c7
allowing for the capture here so now you
don't double my pawns anymore Bishop
takes and e4 so instead of white at
least having this bishop closed up right
by the point in e5 now there will be
possibilities of playing some d5 at some
point to open up the bishop right a
little bit - yes the Queen the queen is
close by that bishop - that's true
that's typically a bad piece you need to
try to find a way for it to either trade
it or something but in this case white
will stay with the center and and the
diagonals for their bishops will be for
the moment better than blacks d5
c4 c5 chasing the bishop away and now
Queen c2 I like this move as well for
for white because I'm strengthening the
c5 pawn considering that these points
will be traded I want to make sure
that's going to be stopped and also with
with before I'm also stopping Queen a5
ideas or a5 ideas and what do I want to
do against f5 a5
you take a tank okay you can take there
with which piece do I take back
well you have to make sure that you're
not losing something here
what do you do now
don't take her the bishop why not with a
bishop well what do you do after after
pond takes I want to take any four yes
it's pretty well known
okay maybe I can just retreat
wait for for you to try to play for for
a win but why don't you like to take
with a bishop I want to keep my queen to
d4 and that way that your bishop will be
passive I have my queen pretty active
which is what I'm thinking
but he played Queen Sita you know he had
a brilliant game and just I suggested
something that maybe nowadays would be
something we'd consider to do but he
finished the development he respected
the principles pawn takes he took him in
a five look did nice move taking the
rock and now you don't really have a
good place for that rock
it's the thing for example if you play
this move what can I do
six
something like this and then you want to
mess up completely blacks black skin
so Ricky Pfeiffer's played by Boogaloo
ball takes with tempo Luke takes a five
what do we do now
Queen c4 check okay King h8
well the first thing look when you have
a position where there are a lot of
pieces in place like hanging you need to
consider the captures first like just
because he took in a 5 it doesn't mean
that he or she calculated everything and
it works and it's perfect
you need to double-check your opponent
always doesn't matter who it is weaker
stronger doesn't matter just
double-check it
see if taking the 5 works rook takes
Bishop takes Queen takes rook takes d4
what do we do now
why to move and win
of course Rock f1 so the position if you
don't have something serious here you
should not be happy with white because
you traded a lot of pieces you had a
little bit like you had the center and
the pieces got traded and now what now
you're the reason you accepted all of
these trades is because blacks King
remained without much protection and
there's a problem there so just look f1
you're bringing the last piece to attack
I like this game and I chose it for
today's class because I I noticed how
white really brought all of their pieces
to attack and even if they trade it not
pretty serious there's a threat how do
you protect it probably would have been
a slightly better choice than them
blacks
still what do we do here after 27
okay and now
can I come back
let's check
well then maybe if Bishop e6 maybe route
d8 so how about wish md5 and then you
want to take black plays rook to d8 you
can okay wait maybe
and you're not losing you have to
question
you can play look do you one but I will
take it
yeah for sure I won't make Queen takes a
faith mistake because I'm retained right
but I will take a look in day one but
the game finished as beautifully after
up the eighth
how did white win and then Bishop e8 and
that's black resigned you probably saw
this final position right this is this
is famous but you know here came the
game that with it and you know basically
it seemed like black was okay because
they just traded everything but the
position is really slightly better for
white and it just went from from this
'if I've it just went it was probably
calculated most of it even here I mean
after Queen c2 it's maybe black should
have tried maybe taking here first and
then taking him before I mean really not
allowing all that those trades but
instead you know with with with this
capture just they didn't see it coming I
mean it seemed like they can get their
palm back but with rook da they're
simply just locating their look there
and there's not so much to do so you
really have to be careful in these
positions if you have the chance in my
opinion to capture the 1985 and double
white spawns you're really stopping
there their attacks it doesn't seem like
White has a lot of attack but when these
bishops open up yeah you know you can
you can fall into a lot of traps so this
was a nice game did you guys like it
great so next we are going to go back to
female chess player the best in the
world most famous one and who has broken
a lot of Records
Judit Polgar and I have chosen a game
that she won against Alexey Shiro
I need to put in training the reason I
chose this to this game and the two
players well first of all you know and I
I really want I think there are a lot of
great great games played by female
players too and although they didn't
manage to become world champions in the
open section they really show great
potential and Alexei Shirov is known for
his dynamic style right he's written a
book fire on the board a lot of you know
attacking attacking chess the game was
played in 1995 and this time it was it
was him who was under attack so let's
see he has chosen actually the modern I
think it's kind of interesting that I
kept you know for today the entire day I
kind of chose games to kind of follow
the same pattern I didn't do it on
purpose but it turned out perfectly so
let's see what happens when a top player
chooses to play something like this
against you know the strongest female of
all time so far Judit Polgar so she went
for the center perfect Bishop g7 93 I'm
not going to comment on the opening too
much because I think there are a lot of
systems that both players can can choose
and okay it's been a while since I
played with either colors.this so we'll
just try to focus on the game as it went
from from the opening to the to the
middle game any questions about the
opening though I'll try to answer to the
best of my ability no okay well okay so
c6 basically with by playing on this
move order black also keeps the option
to play with d5 so kind of combined the
Pyrrhic with with caracal and also c6
you have of course ideas with b5
typically if white plays Bishop c4 this
line should
not work but I've seen people played I
played it myself like maybe 10 years ago
as a kid with black and just give up the
pawn and actually it worked out somehow
but okay at a high level I don't think
this is this is such a great idea so
share of settle for day six Queen f3
subtle subtle threat I remember I mean a
lot of us when we learn to play chess we
learned this idea Bishop c4 Queen f3
checkmate
okay now it's not checkmate but it's
it's a nice approach but you know
showing attacking chess and well you
want your queen to be close to the
attack basically and you're kind of
showing that your knight will not be
developed in f3 to probably go this way
right or through h3 it's really
dependent so Queen f3 threat what do we
do is black yep you six and just because
black has moved for pawn so far it's not
as bad as it might seem because their
idea is that black is going to consider
and play with b5 playing that move with
tempo it's through another pawn move but
this is how this kind of modern
positions work you you give up the
center you change that Bishop attempt or
you'll have Bishop d7 and eventually
you'll develop your pieces and you'll
play some c5 your Bishop will be opened
and black does have pretty you know good
ideas and the attack has been stopped
and the thing is if you don't castle too
fast for white is going to be able to
actually start an attack so what you
have to be careful for though are ideas
with you know if white will have some
ways to trade this Bishop but if you
don't develop the knight just yet maybe
that won't be possible and white will
have to find a way to open up the center
which again is not so simple because any
time one of the pawns pushes the black
will respond with a contra push in the
center so
okay typically nigt to be 597 is of
course another option that the black
would play in this position and just
wait a little bit longer to play b5 so
white often plays we should be three two
as a prophylactic move and then castle
and you know like I said why does have
the center but it's not easy to actually
create any kind of threats and black
skin is fine
but in the game sheriff went for b5
directly Bishop III Bishop d3 is of
course another option games a lot of
games have been played at this position
for some of you who are interested in or
played this with either color
certainly something that you can check
are now a 5 so it's quite clear what
Plex threat is in this position right
and I choose also this game because like
did get punished for not developing the
pieces on time sometimes they don't get
punished but when you see them get
because this is not typically the way
you should play should not move so many
pawns in the opening but ok Shirov likes
to attack so he went for it a3 I've seen
ideas with a 4 stop that as well right
and then before where do we move the
knight where
so where do you want to bring it
eventually would you for maybe two but
see for so you can go this way or this
way you got to figure out which one
works best for you
c4 is a nice square but yeah of course
you can if you bring it in III you have
you're controlling a lot of you have a
lot of idea the game that I had here
actually let's see which game that I put
okay it's a game from 1992 white played
Bishop e3 and okay turned out to be a
pretty balanced position in the game
Judah just went for a three because if
this happens you don't care so much I've
noticed since I'm not an e4 player I I
try to make sense of how you know a lot
of games have been played against the
the the modern and the nineteen see
three when people develop it there they
normally don't like to get it to allow
it to be chased so I've seen them mostly
playing a three very often they'd like
to have the option to go night
more recently in 92 and then going to g3
or f4 rather than allowing before to be
played so if somebody knows otherwise
let me know but that's what I've seen
what I've seen up often so obviously
before it's not possible so visual
basics
what do we do it white
versus castle
you want to play d5 did you say defy
four does black have any ideas in this
position oh yeah
h4 she wants to go you want to go for it
immediately before ideas are certainly
possible here for black defy very good
Casso is another choice of course
probably just finishing finishing up
development and attacking ideas are not
so simple now for white because if I
managed to castle even this like Bishop
e6 mm-hmm so d5 and at that point it was
a novel thing by the way when when she
played it in 95 okay d5 she rose to be
the cheap one and it makes sense I mean
you don't want to take with the e pawn
to open up your king but surprisingly
that was a better move actually taking
with the e pawn takes and yeah
c5 and basically you are going to play
against this Bishop I mean when White
has such a bishop you know you typically
want to have it open to attack on the
diagonal so this would have been a nice
sheer of took with the C pawn what do we
do
and now II five so blacks idea was
similar to the other one that we saw
just that it's a little bit different
because now you're also closing up your
bishop right so what do we do now with
white
wait wait Bishop III Knight e4 any other
ideas
g4 okay oh you want to stop it fine okay
94 let's go for a 94 I mean if you have
the night here trust me nobody will play
a 5 if they will you have a lot of ideas
right so it's it's not you know it's
well there's some lines actually again
in the King's Indian that leg does play
that even if white gets with the 1986
but they have the bishop in c8 and
eventually you know not eventually but
they take the 90 mediatory and it's
playable for black it's a lot of the top
players are playing that but in general
Raja both as part of play the King's
Indian right but yeah thank you
typically don't want if it's good for
you if black plays a 5 so sure I've just
developed normal ok I'm fine I'm going
to develop my queen and the night I'll
Castle pretty good what do we do it
white well we have to finish our
development eventually so Judith decided
to play c4 to kind of be able to do to
do some stuff with tempo first what
other because actually there's a threat
here for black isn't and no there isn't
actually there is no I thought they for
intake but that's not a threat well is
that d6 pawn
what's the idea of the c4 if I take and
night here 93 she played Bishop c6
okay you don't have a clear thread
besides my rook right so let's move it
what next
yeah but no you're going for threats in
one move that are easily easily no no
I'm not saying it to say it in a wrong
you have ideas 196 I'm not going to you
know but typically you want to try to
have more so I don't know if this really
works so bright I mean it's a nice idea
it's you know it's good to have this
kind of ideas because sometimes they
were but I mean you there are positions
where you can make them work but it's
better if you try to to create a plan
and you try to improve and you want to
be able to beat somebody lower rated
than you or about the same level you
want to be better than them you need to
think in plans rather than direct
threats just in one move unless you have
a serious like attacking way of
attacking and developing and continuing
the attack if it's just going to be
helpful for them to develop it's better
to try to and I trust me I understand
you because I have that I had it I
probably still have that problem of
making moves like this when I want to
play attacking chess it doesn't quite
work so it's it's I think I think it's a
little bit white once a little bit too
much from that position it's helping
black a little bit again the piece is
better I mean the special bean a for
right now nobody can attack it it has
the pin if you place it in c6 you
haven't really improved its position too
much from the its you still have the
same idea because yeah it moves the rook
and here similar this night is really
doing a great job here in e4 why because
they are typical ideas to sometimes
sacrifice or just put pressure in d6 and
that can be a dangerous spot for for
black and you will see this game was won
because of this great great idea of the
knight in being in e4 and with the night
here like I said you are attracting f5
so that your knight
go to that place you know on with tempo
and stable night in e6 pretty nice age
she didn't in this position she played
Knight c3 and do you guys know what idea
she has with this Knight like improving
the position of this night so first of
all stopping any kind of c3 for that
Bishop to be opened up or the file or
whatever she's protecting d5 and she has
another idea here well what did they
tell you about the square but ten
potential sacrifices are coming up the
street here with sacrifices and then
bringing the other night I'm not saying
that works immediately but that's coming
up that's an interesting idea and this
is like a I would say you know it's
considered this a prophylactic move but
it's also like an improvement of the
piece and and black played estrangement
in g7 I guess they should have really
got scared about that that sacrifice h6
is interesting to stop this ninety five
ideas and would take work probably not
because now I think you can probably
even take right or no Queen takes
well let's see let's see can I play
Bishop c6 first and then some check then
I check there huh there's an interesting
line I didn't think about or wait why do
I do that can I do that directly I'm
getting tired no who is better here
it's not over but I do have some great
ideas coming up
of course black will try to give up the
Queen but this bishop will be trapped as
well right so but I think we don't need
to take the pawn you know after night 94
black and probably just move the Queen
somewhere where is not going to allow Y
to attack it further like I will take it
this out all the way to b8 and we
basically are not worried about this
pretty it looks pretty bad some confused
why what's happening here I thought this
was not possible for some reason
Quinnie fate ah maybe and then maybe we
should be three to have some ideas or
something like that but maybe black and
hold on can can they just maybe rook c8
it's a crazy it's a crazy position let's
well I will admit that it's probably
maybe that's the reason why why sheriff
thought okay h6 doesn't work
ninety-seven horse of course another
option but then we've got this check
Queen takes and you cannot Castle and
the rookies attack so you need to kind
of move the rook somewhere and ideas
like this a lot of ideas for white so
but why is this game so important and
everyone should know is because now
black play King g7 what did Judy do of
course sacrifice come on which is you
know she's a famous for being you know a
very good dynamic attacking player
Knight takes D six this option cannot be
missed
you know Queen takes if King takes
oopsie
if F five okay you just gave up the pawn
and your king is still in the center the
six is coming it's pretty bad
right so if King takes what do we do
here
Queen takes f7 or 94 which one do you go
for
then then d6 now or if you take there
must be a maid that's coming soon not
sure what's the best but you can take
there and then the King cannot survive I
mean I would be super happy to have that
in a you know in chess same as in bug
house my house it will finish much
faster but chess it's just yeah
basically basically this would be over
so King takes makes no sense or so
Shroff took with the Queen 94 Queen
takes what else that's that's coming up
and the the knight will move and
discover and everything so Queen takes
check and here 90 to f6 what do we do
what should we do in this position with
white what is missing
do we have enough pieces to attack
bringing one more piece this is cool a
cool rule of attacking chess make sure
you use all of your pieces especially if
your opponent has a lot to protect if
you bring all of yours maybe you will
have bigger chances and she certainly
did after rook d1 Queen b7 rook d7 check
brilliant move I love it
what to do and by the way I said good
Queen b7 I went on it pretty fast
what if Queen is 6 what do we do here
same thing we're do the same thing
because I mean if keenya fate what do we
do now
which will ya
pretty bad right and so in this position
after rook d1 Queen B seven roopd seven
you have to sacrifice the Queen what do
what did you do now
well you want to take the Queen I mean
you sacrificed a lot of material I mean
there's no man you don't have enough
pieces guys you cannot watch what to do
it take it
h6 obviously this is not such a great
idea because what not a night takes is
an option hc5 maybe 95 and you go for
the rook better
and what if Bishop d7 actually it's kind
of the only the only chance the black
had but then Bishop a4 just retreat
black has broken the night a night in
the poem for the Queen right and you
know you can play it 6 for example Queen
g3 I mean the DHI continues but it would
have given black a little bit more more
ideas but the final the final the final
of this game is pretty brilliant last
move of the game if unless I forgot it
which I hopefully didn't because then it
would make no sense for me to teach this
the games everyone should know besides
you maybe we should have I'm joking
so why did you display in this position
final move of the game and I love I love
this final move of the game
quindi one so let's see did I did I
forget it
no I didn't who good queen d1 and well I
only put one exclamation should I put
two exclamation points because you know
she won the Queen and this idea would
that on the d6 squared
still did not go away because of you
know the pin and everything and you know
this nineteen before you can see how
strong of a piece this is after after
Queen d1 just sheer of resigned now of
course there's a line that we have to
see that just to understand what is
happening but obviously you can see the
threat so for example if black takes
what do we do with white check
let's try to find the the end of this
beautiful game Bishop e6 check okay King
D eight night X if you do that I don't
know you're gonna you're gonna think
about it you better think about the mate
I don't know if that's mate I mean you
still probably not so sure cuz Queen
sees six now now you help me take the
night out suddenly my rooks protect each
other no be sure before you should be
five check don't let him go in that
direction because look Black has four
pieces on this side of the bar on the
Queen King side on the Queen side he
only has two and it's more open so you
probably have more chances to mate it
there so go with this check King c8 now
I'm going to do that or queen c6 which
one would you go for if I go back well
right
kimby eight
well this is one and this is another
alternative what do we do against this
one yeah simple so there should be seven
don't you interpolate 96-well no it's
not the same thing because 96 attacks
and controlled dead square so when he
protects when you go there's mate but if
you have the bishop in c6 instead of the
19 d6 where's your mate I mean you
should still be winning you can play now
96 fine I'll give you that but anyways
the game ended there after Queen d1 it's
it was like obviously black had some
better choices and it's like in any game
right I mean but the final the final is
always you know the the cool the cool
thing about that is well you know it's I
found it interesting because you know
he's both of them are dynamic players so
it's often a lot of great games come out
of that because you know both players
really want to attack or do something
and then things like this can happen so
hopefully enjoyed today's two games
[Music]
you
[Music]